the existence of our universe is a
puzzle during the Big Bang matter and
antimatter should have been created in
equal amounts and immediately
annihilated each other but somehow
matter prevailed and the universe as we
know it came to be scientists have long
searched for the secret to Matters
dominance now researchers in Japan think
they might have found it or at least a
strong suggestion that differences
exists between particles called
neutrinos and antineutrinos which could
explain why the universe is the way it
is subatomic particles of matter are the
building blocks of our universe but
there's also antimatter particles with
the same mass but opposite electrical
charges in theory a universe made up
entirely of antimatter would be
indistinguishable from our own and
physics would work in exactly the same
way but in 1964 researchers observed
that sometimes nature treats matter and
antimatter slightly differently a
phenomenon known as CP violation by
skewing the balance between matter and
antimatter this helped to explain the
imbalance of the universe but the
discovered differences which happen only
in certain kinds of particles can only
account for a tiny excessive matter
physicists need to find other ways that
nature treats matter and antimatter
differently and that has a much bigger
effect that's what a huge experiment
under a mountain in Japan might have
found the International collaboration is
called Tokai to kameoka or T to K and it
studies near massless particles called
neutrinos a prominent theory says that
in a hot early universe just moments
after the Big Bang distant cousins of
the neutrino could have shown a
preference and whether they broke down
into matter or antimatter and if so that
would be enough to explain today's
imbalance because regular neutrinos
today should show similar behavior
it's a theory that scientists can test
the t2k experiment in Japan does this by
generating two streams of particles one
of neutrinos and the other of anti
neutrinos they shoot these beams from
the seaside village of Tok i2
super-kamiokande a neutrino detector
that lies underneath Mount Aquino 295
kilometers away researchers know how
many particles have been produced in
Tokai which means that they should also
know how many they'd see as to becoming
a candy
if both types of particles behave in the
same way what they found however was
that the neutrino and antineutrino beams
weren't behaving identically today's
result is the strongest evidence yet
that a difference exists in the behavior
of neutrinos and antineutrinos a
difference which could then be enough to
explain the imbalance of matter and
antimatter in the universe but this is
only the beginning of the story the
latest observation is evidence for their
behavior but researchers can't be sure
there's about a one in 370 chance that
the same discrepancy could occur through
random variations to be certain they'll
have to gather much more data probably
with a whole new generation of
experiments large-scale experimental
setups are already under construction
hyper kamiokande in Japan and Jun in the
United States these experiments will be
used to untangle the physics of
neutrinos further and will hopefully
provide answers to one of the greatest
mysteries surrounding the origin of our
universe
you